[Musique]
la seule mesure en deux ans qui étaient
prises en matière d'immigration par
monsieur macron c'est d'élargir les
possibilités du regroupement familial
c'est la seule mesure concrète
emmanuel macron pense que faire un beau
discours ou annoncé une mesure ces
pratiques et une réforme profonde
ça fait deux ans que c'est du vent qui
est un écart abyssal entre les mots et
les actes parce que sur ce sujet
emmanuel macron n'a pas de combien ça
c'est la politique de sparadrap c'est la
politique cosmétiques pour faire parler
ça marche ce que propose le gouvernement
c'est hors de proportion de la réalité
du merlot
dans notre pays on voit bien que le
gouvernement n'ose pas h accusé ces
majorités de gauche
le bilan des manuels macre en matière
d'immigration est catastrophique on
atteint un nombre record
on l'a vu au parlement d'attribution des
cartes de séjour 90% des déboutés du
droit d'asile c'est à dire qu'on a entre
80 et 90 mille personnes qui demandent
l'asile qu'ils n'ont pas à chaque année
en france et qui ne sont pas renvoyés
dans leur pays c'est ça le vrai sujet de
l'immigration d'abord le gouvernement de
monsieur macron commence par appliquer
la loi et à raccompagner aux frontières
les gens qui n'ont qui sont en situation
illégale à volonté des français et la
volonté de la droite c'est de maîtriser
l'immigration de mieux la contrôler et
surtout d'éviter une immigration de
masse avec emmanuel macron il ya souvent
des discours que l'on peut entendre et
même que l'on peut approuver et puis il
y à des mises en action il ya des actes
qui sont très différents il met sur la
table des sujets qui sont extrêmement
importants pour les français
sans mettre les moyens financiers les
moyens humains les moyens matériels pour
résoudre ces problèmes qui sont lisses
mais quand vous mettez le feu à un
bâtiment et que le risque d'embrasement
le risque de blessure le risque de mort
vous n'êtes pas ami un crétin y en a b
s'il vous est un délinquant
ça fait très longtemps que dans devront
de nombreuses villes de notre pays
quotidiennement la république et tester
des minorités agissantes se croient tout
permis parce que la police n'a pas
suffisamment de moyens parce que
lorsqu'elle en a la justice est trop
lente et parce que même quand la justice
n'est pas trop lente
les sanctions ne sont pas appliquées
avec rapidité et fermeté quand on commet
un incendie volontaire on commet un
crime selon le code pénal et on est
passible des assises
ce n'est pas un petit d'agissements
d'imbéciles celle agissements d'une
organisation mafieuse
[Musique]